es medianoche ya pasó mi hora de dormir
sin embargo yo estoy bastante animado
para hacer estos problemas del st de
hecho vamos en el problema número 5 y me
he propuesto que esta semana a cabo los
vídeos de lezea tema así que manos a la
obra voy a intentar hacer todo lo
posible para acabarlos esta semana y si
no la próxima nos quedamos en el
problema número 5 que por cierto tiene
una gráfica de pastel parecida a ésta
déjame hacer la tengo aquí a mi pastel
okay más o menos así y después parece
parece que está dividido a la mitad y no
de hecho está dividido a la mitad aquí
también está dividido a la mitad de la
mitad ok y después aquí tengo algo más o
menos así ok
donde me dicen que esté déjame cambiar
de herramienta
este es el 25% ok
este es el 20% ok y este es el 30% ok y
además me dan algunos datos con x no sé
bien que signifique pero vamos a ver a
qué se refiere esto aquí me dicen que x
es mayor o igual que 60 x es mayor o
igual que 60 ok aquí me dicen que x es
menor que 20 x es menor que 20 por esta
parte me dicen que 20 han déjeme
escribir aquí 20 es menor o igual que x
que es menor que 40 que es menor que 40
si en efecto y por último aquí tengo que
40 40 es menor o igual que x que es
menor que 60 ok perfecto y que me dice
el problema me dice el gráfico siguiente
muestra los resultados de la edad de mil
personas encuestadas
la edad está representada por x ok aquí
tenemos a las personas que son más
pequeñas de 20 años ok aquellas personas
que son mayores o iguales de 60 años ok
aquellas personas que están entre 40 y
59 años y 11 meses y 30 días es decir 59
años y 364 días ok entre 40 y 60 pero
puede tocar el 40 y aquí x es mayor o
igual que 20 y menor que 40 las personas
que están entre 20 años y 39 años 364
días caen justo aquí ok dicen cuántas
personas contestaron que su edad es
menor que 40 años
buscamos que x ok todas las personas que
cumplan que x sea menor que 40 año pues
vamos a ver
aquí tengo a las personas cuya edad es
más grande o igual que 60 años si su
edad es más grande o igual que 60 años
no es menor que 40 años estás de acuerdo
por lo tanto ésta no va a ser mi
respuesta correcta esto no me sirve
por otro lado aquí tengo a las personas
cuya edad es más grande o igual que 40
años y hasta 60 am si te das cuenta las
personas que tienen 40 años menos que 40
años no son las personas que tienen 40
años o más de 40 años por lo tanto
tampoco me sirve esta respuesta ok
aquí tengo las personas que tienen menos
edad que 20 años y menos edad que 20
años si en efecto cumplen que es una
edad que es menor que 40 años por lo
tanto a todas las personas que tienen un
año 3 años 5 años todas las edades que
son menores a 20 años también son
menores de 40 años por lo tanto esto
esto de aquí va a estar en mi respuesta
de este problema
ok todo esto va a estar en mi respuesta
y por último aquí tengo a las personas
cuya edad está entre 20 mayor o igual
que 20 años y menor que 40 todas estas
personas cumplen que tienen una edad más
pequeña que 40 años este también nos
sirve esto también me sirven y también
va a ser parte de mi respuesta es decir
que mi respuesta es toda esta parte de
aquí que es te das cuenta es justo en la
mitad de este pastel por lo tanto las
personas encuestadas que tienen una edad
menor que 40 años es el 50% es el 50% de
1000 personas encuestadas de mil
personas ok y el 50% de mil personas
pues es 500 500 personas contestaron
personas pero son las contestaron que
tienen una edad menor de 40 años que por
cierto es el inciso de y esta es la
respuesta de este problema lo único que
había que hacer era fijarnos con mucho
cuidado qué es lo que pasaba con mis
igualdades que tengo aquí hoy el
problema número 5 estuvo sencillo vamos
a trabajar con el problema número 6 el
problema número 6 que me dice lo
siguiente problema número 6 cuál de los
siguientes incisos puede ser el residuo
el residuo de 4 enteros positivos
consecutivos si cada uno lo dividimos
entre 3 ok imagínate que aquí tengo a
mis 4 enteros positivos y además son
consecutivos entonces aquí tengo a x
aquí tengo a x + 1
recuerda que x + 1 es el consecutivo de
x aquí tengo a x + 2 y por último aquí
tengo a x + 3 tengo cuatro enteros
consecutivos muy bien ahora a cada uno
de estos los voy a dividir entre 3 pero
como no sé si son divisibles 1 entre 3
voy a suponer en primer lugar que x esté
aquí si es divisible entre 3 si x es
divisible entre 3 entonces cuando yo lo
he vivido entre 3 me da de residuos 0
justo esa es la definición de que un
número sea divisible entre otro que me
dé un residuo de 0 ok si x es divisible
entre 3 x 1 cuando yo lo divido entre 3
me va a dar de residuo 1 estás de
acuerdo si por ejemplo x es 27 28 entre
3 me da de respuesta 9 y me sobra uno
siempre que tengas un número de división
entre 3 su consecutivo va a tener como
residuo 1 y si después me tomo x + 2
bueno pues x + 2 va a tener como residuo
2 por ejemplo 29 entre 3 me da 9 y me
sobran 2 ok pero aquí está la clave de
este asunto si yo me tomo ahora x 3 y lo
divido entre 3 que me va a dar de
residuo bueno pues si te das cuenta se
va a cumplir un ciclo o tengo residuos 0
o residuo 1 o residuo 2 o residuo otra
vez 0 no puedo tener residuo 3 porque 3
es divisible entre 3 si x es divisible
entre 3 x + 3 sin dudarlo entre sí por
lo tanto tiene como residuos cero y
justo aquí está la clave los únicos
posibles residuos entre 3 0 1 y 2 ok
ahora esto pasa si x si el primero es de
aquí tenía era de visiblemente 3 pero
qué pasa si este no es divisible entre 3
y supongamos que deja un residuo de 1
bueno pues si dejan de sido de 1
entonces el que sigue va a dejar un
residuo de 2 el que sigue para dejar un
residuo de cero de cero el que sigue un
residuo de 1 ok recuerda que se cumple
el ciclo 120 120 70 y bueno así no puedo
seguir con el tercer caso que éste no
sea divisible entre 3 y me deja un
residuo de 2 pero vamos a ver mis
sencillos
o que es que el inciso de el existente
me dice justo esto a 0 12 y 0 es uno de
los posibles candidatos para tener un
residuo de tres de cuatro enteros
consecutivos que el primero me dé 0 el
segundo 1 el segundo 2 el segundo 0
hablando de residuos y de hecho es que
no se puede tener un residuo de 3 en el
4 no se puede tener un residuo de 3
porque 3 está invisible entre 3 prueba
tanto me deja haber sido 0 y por lo
tanto a b c y en los cuatro incisos
restantes tienen un 3 o un 4
involucrados y por lo tanto no son mi
respuesta a este problema número 6 la
única respuesta a este problema número 6
es el inciso de ahí que me dice 0 12 y 0
hablando de los residuos de 4 enteros
consecutivos de lujo vamos al problema
número 7 ok pues volvemos la pantalla y
entonces vamos a trabajar con el
problema número 7 el problema número 7
que dice lo siguiente
si tengo la siguiente ecuación la
siguiente expresión y es inversamente
proporcional a x ok sí que es
inversamente proporcional a x eso quiere
decir que ya se ve de la forma k por el
inverso multiplicativo de x es decir 1
entre x esto quiere decir que ya es
inversamente proporcional
cuando digo que es directamente
proporcional a x me quedaría que james
es igual acá x x se multiplica acá por x
sin embargo cuando me refiero que es
inversamente proporcional a x al que me
estoy refiriendo es que ya se ve de la
forma que es decir una constante por uno
entre x por el inverso multiplicativo de
x ok dice sigue es igual a 15 cuando x
vale 5 y es igual a 15 cuando x vale 5
aquí voy a poner a camps o espera aquí
voy a poner a camps por 1 entre 5 ok y
de aquí te podemos despejar acá acá vale
acá es lo mismo que 15 por 5 si paso
este 5 del otro lado multiplicando y acá
es lo mismo que 15 por 5 en lo cuales
75 perfecto esto me sirve bastante
porque ya tengo el valor de cam si acá
vale
75 entonces ya lo puede sustituir aquí
estás de acuerdo yo tengo la función
y es igual a 75 que multiplica a 1 entre
x o 75 entre x estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes ahora que ya sé el valor de
cam ok si tengo que y es igual a 75
entre x lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale y cuando x vale 25 cuanto vale
cuando x vale 25 esencialmente lo que
hay que hacer es poner el valor de x
igual a 25 justo adentro de esta función
y entonces que me va a quedar que james
lo voy a poner aquí que es igual a 75
entre x pero x vale 25 y 75 entre 25 es
lo mismo que 33 por 25 75 y ya está el
valor de ya que soluciona esta ecuación
es igual a 3 porque ya teníamos la
constante y también nos dan el dato de
que x vale 25 ya igual a 3 que por
cierto es el inciso a
ya está aquí tengo la respuesta de este
problema número 7 así que voy a borrar
la pantalla y vamos ser el problema
número 8 que me dice lo siguiente sin
2x más z esto es igual a 2 y por otra
parte 2 x + 2 + zeta esto es igual a 20
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale y
podemos obtener de estas dos ecuaciones
el valor del bien y bueno yo creo que sí
porque fíjate lo siguiente aquí tengo 2
x + zeta esto es igual a 210 2x maceta
esto es igual a 2 y con mucha atención a
esto porque lo vamos a ocupar y aquí
tengo que 2x más 2
+ z esto es igual a 20 o dicho otra
manera esto lo puedo acomodar como dos
equis más zeta el orden de los sumandos
no afecta a la suma me estoy tomando
este y este primero y después a esto le
voy a sumar 210 y esto es igual a 20 lo
único que hice fue escribir esta suma de
una manera distinta y por qué lo hago
porque yo sé cuánto vale 2x maceta 2x
maceta justo estoy aquí si te das cuenta
es lo mismo de aquí arriba y entonces
aquí me dice que 2x maceta estoy en
puedo sustituir a 2x maceta por dossier
de aquí voy a obtener que 2x maceta es
lo mismo que dos bien dos más este otro
2 james más este otro 2 james
esto me dicen que es igual a 20 y de
aquí puedo decir que dos llamados es lo
mismo que cuatro y cuatro y es igual a
20 y es lo mismo que 20 entre 4 lo cual
es
y está de lujo porque esa es la
respuesta de este problema x igual a 5
que también es el inciso am es la
respuesta de este problema y ya está
acabe el problema número 8 y acabe
también este vídeo porque ya estoy
bastante cansado así que mejor nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo donde voy a
resolver más problemas hasta la próxima